What is the largest star in the universe and why is it that large and what
are stars anyway, things that would like to be stars.
We begin our journey with earth, not to learn anything,
just to get a vague sense of scale.
The smallest things that have some Starlight properties are large gas giants,
or sub Brown dwarfs like Jupiter,
the most massive planet in the solar system,
11 times larger and 317 times more massive than earth and more or
less made of the same stuff as our sun, just much, much less of it.
The transition towards stars begins with Brown wolves,
failed stars that are a huge disappointment to their mums.
They have between 13 and 90 times the massive Jupiter.
So even if we took 90 Jupiters and through the mud, each other,
although fun to watch, it wouldn't be enough to create star.
Interestingly, adding lots of mass to a Brown dwarf,
doesn't make it much bigger. Just-it's insides denser.
This increases the pressure in the core enough to make certain nuclear fusion
reactions happens slowly. And the object glow a little.
So Brown dwarfs are a sort of glowy gas giant that don't fit into any
category very well. But we want to talk about stars, not failed,
want to be stars. So let's move on main sequence stars.
Once large gospels pass a certain mass threshold,
their cause become hotter and dense enough to ignite.
Hydrogen is fused to helium and they're cause releasing tremendous
amounts of energy stars that do that are called main sequence stars.
The more massive a main sequence star is the hotter and brighter. It burns.
And the shorter its life is once the hydrogen burning phase is over,
stars grow up to hundreds of thousands of times, their original size,
but these giant phases only last for a fraction of their lifespan.
So we'll be comparing stars at drastically different stages in their lives.
This doesn't make them less impressive,
but maybe it's good to keep in mind that we'll be comparing babies to adults.
Now, back to the beginning, the smallest real stars are red wolves.
About 100 times the massive Jupiter barely massive enough to fuse
hydrogen to helium because they are not very massive. They are small,
not very hot and shine, pretty dimly.
They are the only stars in the main sequence that don't grow once they die,
but sorta of fizz Laos red door.
So are by far the most abundant type in the universe because they burn their
fuel very slowly. It lasts them up to 10 trillion years,
a thousand times the current age of the universe, for example,
one of the closest stars to earth is a red star Barnard star,
but it shines to Dimmi to be seen without a telescope.
We made a whole video on red Wolf's. If you want to learn more, the next stage,
our stars like our sun to say the sun dominates the soda system is not doing
it justice. Since it makes up at 99.8, 6% of all its mass.
It burns far hotter and brighter than red dwarfs,
which reduces its lifetime to about 10 billion years.
The sun is seven times more massive than Barnard star,
but that makes it nearly 300 times brighter with twice its surface temperature
let's go bigger.
Small changes in mass produce enormous changes in a main sequence stars,
brightness. The brightest star in the night sky.
Sirius is two solar masses with a radius, 1.7 times that of the sun,
but its surface is nearly 10,000 degrees Celsius making it shine
25 times brighter burning that heart reduces its total
lifespan. By four times to 2.5 billion years stars
close to 10 times.
The mass of our sun have surface temperatures near 25,000 degrees Celsius.
Beta centaury contains two of these massive stars each shining with about
20,000 times. The power of the sun.
That's a lot of power coming from something only 13 times larger,
but they'll only burden about 20 million years.
Entire generations of these blue stars die in the time it takes the sun to
orbit the galaxy once. So is this the formula?
The more massive, the larger the star,
the most massive star that we know is our one three, six 81.
It has 315 solar masses and is nearly 9 million times brighter
than the sun. And yet, despite its tremendous mass and power,
it's barely 30 times the size of the sun.
The star is so extreme and barely held together by gravity that it loses
321,000 billion tons of material through its stellar wind.
Every single second stars of this sort are extremely rare
because they break the rules of star formation a tiny bit.
When supermassive stars are born,
they burn extremely hot and bright and this blows away any extra gas that could
make them more massive.
So the mass limit for such a star is around 150 times. The sun,
the stars like are one, three, six, eight,
one are probably formed through the merger of several high mass stars in den
star,
forming regions and burn that core hydrogen in only a few million years.
So this means they are rare and short-lived from here,
the trick to going bigger, isn't adding more mass to make the biggest stars.
You have to kill them. Red giants.
When main sequence stars begin exhaust the hydrogen in their core,
it contracts making it hotter and denser.
This leads to hotter and faster fusion,
which pushes back against gravity and makes the outer layers swell in a giant
phase. And these stars become truly giant. Indeed.
For example, God Crocs only 30% more massive than the sun.
It has swollen to about 84 times its radius still.
When the sun enters the last stage of its life,
it will swell and become even bigger.
200 times its current radius in this funnel phase of its life.
It will swallow the inner planets. And if you think that's impressive,
let's finally introduce the largest stars in the universe. Hyper giants,
hyper giants are the giant phase of the most massive stars in the universe.
They have an enormous surface area that can radiate an insane amount of light
being so large.
They're basically blowing themselves apart as gravity at the surface is too
weak to hold onto the hot mass, which is lifted away in powerful stellar wins.
Pistol star is 25 solar masses,
but 300 times the radius of the sun,
a blue hyper giant aptly named for its energetic blue Starlight.
It's hard to say exactly how long pistol star will live,
but probably just a few million years,
even larger than the blue hyper giants or the yellow hyper giants.
The most well-studied ISRO Cassiopeia a so bright.
It could be seen with the naked eye,
although it's thousands of light years from earth at 40 SOTA masses.
This star is around 500 times the radius of the sun and
500,000 times brighter.
If the earth were as close to RO Cassiopeia, as it is to the sun,
it would be inside is and you would be very Dez yellow,
hyper giants are very raveled, only 15 and own.
This means they're likely just a short-lived intermediate state as a star
grows or shrinks between other phases of hyper lists.
With red hyper giants, we reached the largest stars known to us,
probably the largest stars even possible.
So who's the winner of this insane contest? Well,
the truth is we don't know.
Red hyper giants are extremely bright and far away,
which means that even tiny uncertainties in our measurements can give us a huge
margin of error for their size worse, still red hyper giants,
our solar system size behemoths that are blowing themselves apart,
which makes them harder to measure as we do more science and our instruments
improve whatever the largest star is, we'll change.
The star that is currently thought to be among the largest we found is Stevenson
two 18. It was probably born as a main sequence star, a few tens of times,
the mass of the sun and has likely lost about half its mass.
By now while typical red hyper giants are 1,500
times the size of the sun,
the largest rough estimate places at Stevenson two 18 at
2,150 solar radiation and shining with almost half a
million times. The power of the sun by comparison,
the sun seems like a great of dust.
Our brains don't really have a way of grasping this kind of scale.
Even at light speed, it would take you 8.7 hours to travel around at once.
The fastest plane on earth would take around 500 years,
dropped on the sun.
It would fill Saturn's orbit as it evolves.
It will probably shed even more masks and shrink down into another hotter hyper
giant phase accumulate heavy elements in its core before finally
exploding in a core collapses supernova,
giving its gas back to the galaxy.
This gas will then go on to form another generation of stars of all sizes,
starting the cycle of birth and death. Again, to light up our universe.
Let's make this journey again, but this time without the talking,
the universe is big. There are many large things in there.
[Inaudible].
If you want to play a bit more with size stuff, we have good news.
We've created our first app universe in a nutshell together with Tim urban,
the brain behind wait,
but why you can seamlessly travel from the smallest things in existence,
past the Corona virus, human cells and dinosaurs,
all the way to the largest stars and galaxies and Marvel at the whole observable
universe,
you can learn more about each object or simply enjoy the sheer scale of it.
All the app is inspired by the scale of the universe website,
by the human twins that we spent a lot of time with when it came out years ago
and felt that it was finally time to create a wait, but why and coats,
Zack version, you can get it in your app store.
There are no in-app purchases and no ads. All future updates are included.
And since this is our first app,
we'd love to hear your feedback so we can improve it over time.
If this sounds good to you,
download the universe in a nutshell app now and leave us a five star review.
If you want to support it.
[inaudible] and all the projects we do are mostly funded by viewers like you.
So if you liked the app, we'll make more digital things in future.
Thank you for watching.
Right?